Alright, so we've looked at
projected IR versus natural light.
What are the advantages of this
projected light, or projected IR?
Well, yes it works in low light.
You're not counting on
having external light.
You're not counting on having texture
that you can deal with since I'm
projecting this texture, and its okay if
I've got repeated things because I'm,
I'm it's not actually repeated
in a speckle pattern.
Remember we had this problem
with picket fences in stereo?
How all the pickets look alike, to know
which picket it is, is a challenge.
Well, if you painted all the pickets
different colors or different speckles,
that's not a problem, and
that's what the connect does.
And in particular, you can tailor your
algorithms to the actual pattern that
you're producing and
engineer the thing to work really well.
What are the advantages
of natural light?
Well it's natural light.
So it works outdoors, it works
in sunlight, it works, you know,
it just works whenever it's,
the lights are turned on.
Doesn't work in the dark, that's okay,
neither do I, but the idea is that,
you know,
you're just basically using the scene.
The other thing is that you don't have
to worry about the resolution of your
projection, you've got the whatever
at your high-resolution sensors.
It's a lot easier to build
high-resolution sensors than
high-resolution projectors.
Both of them have some difficulties,
you know,
they, they if you have very
shiny surfaces, all right, or
specular surfaces like a mirror, right,
so your projection is going to go.
And, you know, clearly,
if I'm doing stereo and I'm a robot, and
I'm looking at a mirror, I see the thing
that's up there and I think oh,
I could just reach down here and get
that light that's on this, oh no, okay?
It actually, the,
it doesn't see the table.
And my projector, well,
it projects down so
it'll also be thinking about
the ceiling, all right?
So, doesn't work in any of those cases.